- [Instructor] So we
tend to view evolution
and natural selection and
the formation of new species,
which is often called speciation,
as a slow process that could take
tens or hundreds of thousands of years,
or, in many cases, millions of years.
And that's why it's always
interesting to see examples
of when it might actually be happening
more on a human timeframe.
So this right over here is a picture
of a male Central European blackcap.
So historically Central European blackcaps
would spend their
summers in Central Europe
right over here,
in what we would now consider Germany.
So let me write summer right over here.
And then, when it gets
colder in Central Europe,
they would migrate and spend
their winters in Spain.
So this is where they
would spend their winters.
Now, whenever we talk about
migratory patterns like this,
it's always interesting to note
that it's not that all
of the birds always go
on the exact same migration path.
As we've talked about in many videos,
you tend to have
variation in a population.
There are birds that because
of genetic differences,
they might go in other directions.
They might go that way,
they might go that way,
they might go that way.
But those variants probably
weren't successful.
Some of them might end
up in the North Sea.
up freezing to death.
Some of them might not be
able to have sources of food
while the dominant variant
that wintered in Spain
was successful.
It was warmer there.
They had access to food.
Now, this is where it gets interesting.
In the 1960s and 1970s, it
became more and more popular
to put backyard bird feeders in England.
And so some of those
Central European blackcaps
just happened to go in that direction.
They might've always been
happening to go there,
some small percentage of the population,
but those didn't do so well.
But now all of a sudden you
had these backyard bird feeders
in England, and so these birds were able
to be quite successful.
They were able to get food.
They were able to thrive.
And so over time, this became
a larger and larger proportion
that was able to successfully
go in that direction
and then migrate back in the
summer and then reproduce.
Now, not only did that gene
not get selected against,
and now the birds that had the genes
to go in that direction were thriving,
but they also started
mating with each other
more and more frequently
because they would all get
back to Germany earlier.
Because when the winter ended,
they had a shorter distance
to travel on the way back
than the ones that went to Spain.
And so as they started
reproducing with each other
more, and more, and more,
we started to see differences
beyond migration direction
in these two groups of
Central European blackcaps.
The ones that traveled northwest
started to see rounder wings
versus pointier wings for the ones
that were historically going to Spain.
Well, pointier wings are better
for traveling long distances
and rounder wings are more maneuverable,
and if you don't have to
travel as long of a distance
that is more desirable.
Now, it's not like these birds knew
that they needed rounder wings.
But once again, even in
the pool that was going
to the northwest, you
would have had variation,
some pointy wings, some round wings.
But the round wings might've
been more successful
so that became a more
pronounced trait in that group.
While, similarly, the
ones that went to Spain,
some of them might've had rounder wings,
but they might not have been as successful
to get all the way to Spain and back
so the pointier wings, that
phenotype, seemed to thrive.
So this is an example how
an environmental change,
and here the environmental
change is people deciding
to put bird feeders in
their backyards in England
in the 1960s and 1970s,
has actually over just
the course of roughly
30 or 40 generations
began what some biologists
view as a speciation event.
The ones that go northwest
can still interbreed
with the ones that go to the southwest.
But over time, if the
two groups keep breeding
amongst themselves because of
the timing of their migration,
they might not be able
to interbreed anymore
and then you would have
two different species.
So this is just one example.
There are many other examples
about how the physical
environment can contribute to
the expansion of some species,
the emergence of new distinct species,
or, in certain situations,
cause a decline in the species
and, in the extreme. an extinction,
which we'll talk about in another video.